after taking the country music world by  storm after the release of her debut  single my church in 2016  meritorious has quickly become a  commercial success and for the  fastest-rising country music stars now  only four years later she has several  top-ten hits under her belt and a CMA  Award winning album for her sophomore  record girl all before the age of 30 and  let's not forget her 2018 collaboration  with Zedd on the middle which became one  of the biggest pop hits of the year to  celebrate meirin's milestone 30th  birthday on April 10 we're rounding up  her toughest noms  [Music]  [Music]  and  yeah  [Applause]  [Music]  [Music]  good restaurant  that's good shot a little bit  [Music]  the balls are good  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  can I get it  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  so did all of your favorite songs make  our list let us know in the comments  below